platinumba
2042 i'm going to start playing
different openings by the way
now let's continue playing the king's
indian though
no rookie is not senseless you have the
f8 square there
it again with the close position you can
move back to f8 okay so we have a kings
indian
castles and uh e5 this is the main line
this is the main line of the king's
indian and my opponent now
we're playing serious people he plays
the
petrosian variation the trojan variation
is where white immediately pushes d5
after the game
i will talk a little bit about king's
indian theory now
one of black's main ideas in this
position is to put the knight on c5
the move d5 has weakened the c5 square
and from that square
black can attack e4 but there is a
problem if you put the knight on c5
prematurely white can chase it away with
the move b4
so a very typical king's indian move is
to play a5
preventing b4 and preparing to deploy
the knight to c5 either via d7 or via a6
okay bro this is basically prophylaxis
it also grabs space on the queen side
and that's good as a standalone
phenomenon now what is the main plan
here for either side
white prepares the queen side attack
and black attacks on the king side what
does it mean to attack on the king's
side here
there is one very typical idea that
basically starts out
all kings indian attacks on the queen
side could somebody spell out this idea
for me
now let's be general though it's to move
the knight
and then to push the f pawn out to f5
but we don't just want to shove the
knight anywhere we want to put the
knight on a square where it also does
something
and one very typical maneuver is to go
knight h5
with an eye toward going knight f4 we
don't need to go knight f4 immediately
but that's something we can keep an eye
but wait a minute
let's support the knight on c5 first
before we go five how can we do that how
can we make sure that
you know this knight is very nicely
supported before we play f5
another typical king's indian move we
can play the move b6 very patient
very patient move and now i'm going to
show you something kind of cool
so white is threatening before he's not
actually threatening it and i'll show
you guys that too after the game how can
we prevent that we can play a4 but wait
i hear you saying
and he probably is going to and that's a
mistake we give upon have we blundered
it no we haven't we've sacrificed it
why have we sacrificed it because of
something called the dark squares
now how can we exploit the dark squares
in the fastest possible way
not the b file the dark squares what can
we now do what move is possible knight
of four is typical but i want something
nicer
bishop h6 this by the way ladies and
gentlemen is at
another very typical kingdom we are
setting up some beautiful ideas
we are actually threatening checkmate
which you just missed
it is already checkmate and we can
actually oh
so there is a utilitarian mate but let
me show you guys
okay so so bishop e3 check
and let me think so
what's the simplest mo of course the
simplest is to play queen h4
and knight g3 check do you guys want me
to do it
do you guys want me to show you
something really cool we're gonna do
this
let's yeah and what is my idea i will
i will show you everything what is no
not queen h4
it's not going h4 what do you always
need to check when you have a two move
idea what happens
if i play the second move first boom
goes the dynamite
and after he takes queen g5 and
checkmate
is unstoppable now i didn't invent any
of this
i've seen it before i will explain
everything now i know
that not everybody plays the king's
indian and that's why the premise of the
speed run is not to fixate on openings
because
i'm respectful of the fact that people
play different openings
so i'll try to keep things relatively
brief opening wise but i highly
recommend the king's indian
anybody who's an attacking player okay
so first of all to recap right e5 e5
does not blunder the pawn
because if we take the pawn or let's say
this is the exchange variation this is a
viable line
but to take the pawn here is not a good
idea because it allows knight takes c4
exposing the attack on the knight
takes and bishop takes e5 one very
important detail
why can try the desperado sacrifice
knight takes f7
and if we take the knight white's gonna
end up upon up what can black do here
to refute this who can who can tell me
how
black refutes this without this the
king's indian would not have existed
a c5 is viable but that's the more
benoni-like approach
bishop c3 and king f7 nicely done guys
so that's the tactical reason the king's
indian works he goes d5 he defines the
center immediately
this is called the petrossian variation
after tiger and petrossian the main line
is to castle and here actually black has
the additional option of taking on d4
rare line but i like it and we won't
delve into this right now
but he goes d5 so a5 right stopping b4
then we get the knight to c5 and now by
playing f3 he has cut contact with the
h5 square
so in the king's indian generally
there's three ways of preparing a 5
right you can step away to e8
and then go f5 and then go back to f6
you can go to d7 although this is more
rare but this does have the benefit of
supporting the knight
it does however block the bishop
sometimes you can even go king h8 knight
ge
kasparov patented this idea in numerous
five gifts itself to the community
keeps that 3am hype going 4 a.m hype
going thank you and umarus
for five gifted two midnight rhino le
sergei walrus punk
pabs and j curse loving it loving and
loving it
okay um so we go knight h5 he goes
bishop e3
b6 and a4 has a foco thanks for the tier
one
now let's let me first explain why in
like a grand master game i would not
have gone a4
so if we go f5 and he goes before black
is a very cool idea now
how do you gauge the success before you
gauge the success of before
if the knight has to move somewhere like
or
black then white's gonna get c5 in and
this is successful
could anybody tell me how black can
respond to the move before
in a very good way and this actually is
a typical king's indian idea
it's not f4 at force you can just drop
the bishop back i'll give you a hint
takes takes
and now what additional pretty
maneuvered is black cowboo
and that look at this beautiful juicy
knight on d4 this actually helps black
so this is a very important
subtle idea for kingzinian experts to
know but i played a4 to illustrate a
concept
now first of all why did we stop before
because we cannot piss on him
but he immediately sees the pawn and
takes it
right if he goes f4 then we will take it
and now look at this beautiful bishop
and look at this outpost on e5 this is
generally what happens
does that make sense so he takes the
pawn immediately and we play bishop h6
deploying the bishop and look at these
dark squares all around white's king
that's the importance of squares
you know when you weaken a whole complex
of squares like this
you're gonna be in big trouble but
should be three is basically an
unstoppable threat
if he tries to stop it with queen b3
what simple tactical motif does black
have
and this basically transposes into the
game
yeah rook takes bishop e3 and if he
covers it we can go queen h4
g3 oops sorry not queen g3 but knight g3
uh and this is absolutely crushing okay
many top players of kings indian experts
including ikaro
he's played some brilliant games queen
v3 so that's what would have happened
there he goes b4
unaware of what's about to befall him
now bishop e3
why is rook takes a4 necessary we
use the technique of thinking backwards
to find rook takes a4 we begin by asking
why can i not do this
followed by queen she five threatening
queen h6 who can tell me
what defensive resource white has it
doesn't save the game white will still
be lost
but who can smell and sniff out how
white prolongs the game
f4 is correct and bishop h5 and of
course taking with the queen here
wouldn't be impossible
you could take on a4 now and win but
white's not going to take the rook
that's going to be obvious
but thinking backwards we say wait a
second if white's queen could be made to
disappear from d1
then this would be checkmate because h5
would not be defended by the queen right
um so oh and by the way i see why i was
unable to find games
uh in in chess base so as you guys are
thinking
i am going to make another search here
to show you guys if i can find any
um ideas here okay i found a couple yeah
so we we therefore take on a4 first
forcing the queen out and now we give a
check of course
queen h4 would have been winning in fact
it would not be trackmate immediately he
could try to go h3
but this would be a very straightforward
mate in a couple moves
right definitely don't trade the dark
square bishop now that doesn't mean you
never do this
but you can see the danger of weakening
a complex of squares
white should have gone knight d3 here
but still knight b39d4 and black is
better
so against the averbach i'm getting a
question about a very specific line of
the king's indian
uh again i'm gonna try not to stray too
deeply into theoretical waters but the
upper back is where white develops the
two bishops first
what i do here is queen to e8 getting
out of the pin preemptively so that i
can play e5
and then if d5 you can go knight a6
knight c5 kinda like we did in the game
so let me now see if i can pull up a
game
where you will be able to see a very
similar concept
uh oh i see already several
possibilities
now oh here's a beautiful one here is a
beautiful one guys
from a pretty high level game 2300 so
what i'm showing you
serious players are uh you know
they so this is a king's indian game in
which literally all of the ideas we just
applied
were applied by this by by a pretty good
player
so this is a game between two russian
players uh pretty competent you guys can
see 2192 was black 2332 was white
watch now petrossian variation
literally the same position we had white
played bishop g5 first
here's b6 right i'm not making this
stuff up these are legitimate ideas
and black actually provoked f3 here's
not h5
and hero black did something very
interesting play bishop f6
preparing to to get the bishop to g5
weakening white stark squids white
captured the pawn
and black still played bishop g5 and
hear white made
the decisive mistake bishop takes f8
who can tell me what black did in this
position
boom
boom and now
boom but here use careful guys you have
to apply the concepts
in a smart way because the move queen g
queen h4 there is knight f1 by the way
queen h4 immediately here there's knight
f1
and now all of a sudden white defends so
it's not queen g5 there's a better way
of doing this
and you always have to look for the
executions that are
suited to the position when you're
applying a pattern guys very very
important
don't autopilot the execution of an idea
all right
queen g5 knight f1 is a little bit less
clear queen takes f8
knight f1 queen h69c and now black found
the showstopper what's the final move of
the combination this is a slightly more
difficult
position to execute this in verizon king
g7
and once again you can go rook h8 but
the beautiful mate
is takes in rocket shape winning the
game
white's only way to stop this would be
g4 but then just rook hg
and white resigned in this position oh
here's how a 2300
fell prey to precisely the sequence of
moves so you see
this stuff is real this stuff is applied
and it's applied in games between
pretty good players whoops speed one
all right let's do one more
what what about king f1 oh yeah yeah
sorry uh
king ah there was king f1 there was i
think queen h4 that was
a terrible game oh yeah okay let's do
one more
yeah white certainly didn't play well by
the way make no mistake why
white did not have a good day he
shouldn't have taken the rook that was
a mistake a 2300 uh
shouldn't make but they do i mean
they make them they make them too
everybody's human
yeah um i'm on a roll today careful
let's go yeah i know i know sir oh
we're playing the same guy we played
last time who almost beat me
okay so let's play an accelerated we're
playing chess lebanese sal i was at
2100 and almost beat me the last time
okay so we're going to take and play the
accelerated
and he's going to play the muratsi
buying the best line that white has
now here let me actually think about
this for a second
what we're going to do we're going to
play the move
we're going to play the move d6 i'm
going to show you guys a pretty cool
system
against the accelerated now normally
black develops to g7 with the bishop but
i like a more rare system
that i think is dangerous but he
actually finds the right way to skirt it
bishop b3 wow
this guy is the real deal oh i should
have got knight f6 actually
okay whatever we'll just transpose them
to the main line i i
i messed up the move order we have to
transpose into the main line
um we have to transpose into the main
line okay knight f6
and i'm going to show you guys some of
the key ideas
of the accelerated dragon i'm assuming
that he doesn't know this that well
now the marotzi bind in my opinion if
white wants to get an advantage against
the accelerated
he should play the marotzi by that's
really the only
very very testing system against the
accelerated
and uh let's see how well he knows the
ideas now
how do we understand because this guy is
underrated and really really good
i ask for you guys understanding i'm
going to play a little bit faster and
i'm going to play
maybe with a little bit less explaining
than usual and then after the game i'll
be sure to compensate
now right now we're just going to
develop our bishop to d7 so far we've
just been developing our pieces there's
nothing to explain
basically black's idea is to play on the
queen side
and in order to play on the queen side
black will have to
black will have to operate according to
the following formula first
and foremost you need to you need to
grab space on the queen side
okay but in order to grab space we need
to refocus our pieces a little bit let's
take on d4
and where do you guys think we'll put
this bishop on d7
where will we put this bishop on d7
we should put it on c6 all right that's
just a good solid square
and when i say grab space on the queen
side what do i mean by that what i mean
by that
is we'll need to play a5 a4 and
that will allow us to put that clamp
down on the queen side so that we can
then
deploy our queen to a5 and start
attacking him this is
white is slightly better here according
to the computer objectively white is
better
no doubt about it white's got more space
he's got the central control but
but in my experience this is hard to
play
uh accurately for a human being knight
t5 is good
knight t5 is a good move now let me
thank you for a moment
because i myself don't play the
accelerated full-time so this is this is
new to me as well
okay so we're going to take that night
with a bishop
and after the game i will explain uh
why i did that like fully but but there
is a reason behind it
let me just write this down now what
pieces do we want to trade
his puns his pawns are on the light
squares
what do we want to trade if and i'll be
more specific which of the two bishops
do we want
white to give up we
want to give up the dark script bishop
because the light squared bishop is kind
of lame right
a lot of the pawns are on the same color
as his bishop i don't put a lot of stock
in that principle
but here it's a good idea to apply now i
i see you guys thinking well wait a
second
aren't isn't it weakening to give up our
fiance bishop
isn't that bad look it's not great
that's a concession right but
there's not that many pieces left in the
first place so uh in my estimation it's
not like he'll be able to attack my king
furthermore okay goes f4 that's an
interesting move
and a very i think a very good one he
expands preemptively on the king side
so he will try to attack us on the
king's side should we give up this
bishop well
i have no choice i kind of have to give
up this bishop
uh otherwise my whole strategy with 97
my whole campaign is just not that good
and we have a decision to make
do we trade queens queen b6
unfortunately
conceptually this is good uh concretely
this is bad because if queen takes b6
knight takes b6 and the rook penetrates
to cesar
so let's look at this knight for a
second it's stuck in no man's land where
can we put it
king's indian style with nazi fob girl
and what move does this open the
possibility of in terms of expanding on
the queen side
in terms of expanding on the queen side
what is now possible
we can play yeah we can play a4 but um
we can play a4 but that's that's missing
well actually yeah
we will play a4 we why why
first of all we're grabbing space second
of all what he wanted to do very sneaky
guy that he is is play a4 himself
and cement that bishop that splinter in
our throat
at least the bishop is now stuck and
it's not as well defended
how should we attack that bishop
how should we attack that bishop
we can play queen a5 but i like queen b6
which creates
a standoff between the queens and i feel
like i like the standoff because i'm in
control of it
the piece that's between two pieces if
it's protected by a pawn that's a pretty
specific principle but i think it might
be a good one
if you have a standoff between two
pieces and the piece in in the middle of
it is your piece
and it's protected by a pawn you're
usually in control of that standoff
which means i'm usually the one here
who's going to decide whether and if to
trade queens which is a pretty powerful
thing to do
uh well before i can understand him okay
so let's improve our position how can we
do that could somebody name
a simple improving move bringing a piece
into the game
yeah rook sierra okay here we have see
this further supports the knight which i
like
and i would have also considered playing
a3
okay so he goes king a very good move
very good move
and now i want to continue expand i'm
gonna go queen b4
this is a very sneaky move um
because i want him to play a3
i want him to play a3
and why do i want it to play a3 because
it weakens something
what does the move a3 weaken could
somebody answer
me this question while he's thinking the
b3 square
and i could potentially fork him on that
square so he goes e6
okay let me calculate for a second
i'm just uh calculating a little bit
here
there's some really cool cool lines oh
so what can we do here what we can do
is we can play the immediate move b5
and this is not that simple as it seems
it seems like we're winning the bishop
because the bishop came over because of
them but what can he do
dude dude what can you do dude what can
he do
and i'm gonna i'm gonna pre-move rook
takes f7 check
what can we do if we move the queen
then what the hell did we do this for so
what's the tactic who sees it
i think we have a beautiful idea knight
b3
now there's two things we're exploiting
here if he takes the knight i take his
queen
and if he takes my queen i take his and
look at the superiority that we now have
uh our knight is guarding b5 we've got
pressure on all
at all angles here we play rook takes f7
once his bishop moves
we're gonna take his rook take the pawn
on f4 and we're gonna have a winning end
game
so um which which we'll have to win by
playing precisely
once again i have to give big props to
my opponent he's really really good
but it seems like he's going down here
we're going to take the pawn
and now we need to reassess the
situation
how are we actually going to
specifically win this position well
we're going to go after his queen side
pawns and with that in mind where should
we put the rook
where should we put the rook and this
should come automatically
to you guys but now there's actually
several ways to do it yeah rook f2 is
correct
attacking the font forcing his rook to
get passive and now we're just going to
grind them down here
we're going to grind them down now one
very important principle i've shared
with you guys many times in the past
never stop looking for tactics no
matter how many pieces are left on the
word one two and that's exactly what you
guys are doing
checkmate on h2 i think we actually
played a super nice game
i'm curious to see what our what
is i don't usually do this but i'm
actually curious i feel like
i'm into this game and we're 2 000.
yeah 88.3 not that good you never know
what your accuracy is sometimes you feel
good great
you don't play well vice versa okay
let's analyze
i i don't think it likes the accelerated
now the line that i was going to
actually play starts with knight f6
i was going to recommend this line where
you get the queen to d4 so that when you
fianchetto
you create the extra but i'm not gonna
talk about that right now we
transitioned into the main line of the
accelerator
now as you guys know
uh black is cramped right that's the the
main
appeal of the marotzi is is white clamps
down on black center
making me essentially move around on the
first three ranks that's not to
everyone's liking but i like these kinds
of openings so we take on d4
reposition the bishop and we start
expanding on the queen side our idea is
to go a5 a4
and then queen a5 and i actually think
his move was a bit of a positional error
and um the reason why is that he's
trading a lot of pieces and from a space
advantage perspective that's not the
wisest thing to do but it's also
not the wisest thing to do because he's
going to leave himself with a pretty
lame bishop
now here's the thing in these positions
can i ask you guys
the following question could a case be
made for the move e takes d5
is does this move contain any kind of
sense
and i'll tell you preemptively black is
is doing well here
but i want to use this opportunity to
make an instructive
what i think is a pretty instructive
point what is the case that could be
made for this move
yeah miso superior correct on you the
seven punt this week and there
oh there's a classical game that is
shown
to all russian trained school boys if
you want a
little sneak preview to the russian
school of chess this is shown to every
little russian schoolboy
and watch this ladies and gentlemen i'm
going to run through this game very very
quickly this is not a famous game i
don't think
many of you know this game and i don't
mean to be
condescending and i say that i just it's
just not a very famous game unless
you've been trained in the russian
tradition but vinik against hola kevich
bogmenick was 16 when this game was
played he had learned chess at 12.
and while this is not an accelerated
dragon
you get the same exact structure look at
the morozzi structure and guess what
happens
knight d5 knight takes d5
e takes d5 not c takes d5 but he takes
d5 now
i want you guys to look at this and tell
me what is the main difference
between this position
and e takes d5 in my why didn't i say
that black was fine
in my game but he's not fine here
because no knight
the key is that there is no knight i'm
asking not
specifically and henry did yeah so the
key is that there is no knight in the c
file well the c file is closed there too
the knight in such a position can take
all these outposts and it can
essentially
slice off the artery to the e7 pawn
and that is the whole difference black
has this lame dark squared light squared
bishop
and the result of this is that white
just piles up on the e file look how
classically he
he does this now he pressures the queen
city drives the pawn to b6 cements it
trades off the rook on the c file blacks
only trump guard
now he gets a rook of his own to the c
file and he finishes the game
with what very pretty idea this ends the
game
and it's very fitting where this occurs
because that's the whole
bottom line point of this strategy queen
e6 check
if you don't trade queens white takes
and promotes if you do
d takes c6 and b7 and batman nick will
promote his pawn upon is actually
unstoppable nick against philip kievich
very famous game well to russian uh
players and you can see the idea very
clearly defined here
okay now you guys are all familiar with
it and i'm actually very happy
i'm really pumped that you guys are now
aware of this game
so let's compare that to this position
it seems very similar
but this knight could be either on e5 or
on c5
uh promoting the queen side pressure and
that makes all the difference okay
so at this level when we when we hit
2000
uh it's all about making these subtle
observations again
the method of comparison comparing one
position to another position what is
different that helps you
understand and categorize imbalances and
that really builds your positional
understanding when you're able to look
at a position
and detect the key difference uh then
you get better at evaluating these kinds
of positions
okay so he played c takes d5
we take on d4 but and again if we go
queen b6 here
then uh this would be a good trade we're
not for rook c7 very concrete
and he goes so knight c5 bishop b5 a4
very important move otherwise he goes a4
now we put play queen b6 we improve our
position with rook c8
we pin the bishop with queen b4 by the
way a3
my intention was to go knight b3 anyway
and uh the queen trade as we kind of saw
in the game is beneficial for us
now we could have locked everything up
with that five first that would have
been sensible but here i calculated some
lines
so had he taken first and gone a3
we still go knight b3 and this um it
does matter which rook goes to see it
how did i decide with casey because rick
fc8 would have abandoned the king
and i'm not saying i would have paid the
price for it but something like f5 at
some point could have been very scary
at least here i keep a little security
detail on my king
right does that make sense a little bit
of a general answer but hopefully that
that's how i decided it now here there's
a couple of important details if he
moves his queen away
reinforcing the attack on my queen there
seems to be a pretty big problem this is
what i had to see
if i move my queen away he takes the
knight and he wins a pawn
but what key resource does black have
here
what key resource does black have here
um one sec i'm writing down this
this uh which rook
yeah queen c5 is very important or queen
d2s uh
and uh this is fine and i calculated
this that lime doesn't end there
bishop takes b5 but it's only here that
black demonstrates the important
resource
rook to b8 attacking the bishop winning
b2
so without this move and that's what it
boils down to why it would have been
better
so i calculated this he made it easy for
us by trading immediately
and his position just collapses we take
take and now we're going to have three
with a checkmate isn't knight d2
stronger uh
maybe not sure windy two is also good
so the the server is restarting uh so
i'll take this opportunity to talk
briefly about
a question that bothers a lot of people
which is um any questions by the way
which is which rook to put on a
particular course how do you decide what
is the decision logic
that you can apply um that you can apply
in deciding which rook to put on a
particular square
now well you don't coin flip exactly so
there's a couple of things
the sort of baseline method
that i well 2g6 allows queen takes d4
which is a separate line
um the baseline method that i um that i
propose to apply
is to think about when you decide which
rook to put on a square
and you have a candidate move you look
at the other rook you always
look at the rook that's left out from a
square
and in doing so you try to assess
whether that other rook will have any
prospects
uh or not because oftentimes so that's
like method number one
and then method number two you always
have to factor in future ideas
so method number one you try to find a
position for both rooks
uh you don't just myopic you look at one
the second concept is
you need to figure out what your
long-term ideas are and long-term ideas
can involve keeping your king safe
as well as your opponents long-term
ideas and sometimes
it's very important for one rook to be
in charge of being
able to promote a long-term idea maybe
that idea will occur 15 moves down the
line
but that could be a very viable reason
to keep a rook on a particular square
so those two things i would say uh
formula you know sort of form the main
basis for deciding but
every situation is different and i don't
want to oversimplify this is a very
uh you know this is a very serious
question so for example
let's do let's do some very very quick
practice in this
just one one example
this is going to be kind of tricky so
bear with me please
yeah so let's let's let's apply this
logic
precisely here with one of my games from
2015 my worst tournament ever i dropped
like 30 points but
i did win round one so in this position
my opponent plays queen takes queen
jq and a ls thing for the prime which
rook should i recapture with rook a61
or rook after 81 let's think about this
for a second and i'd like somebody to
raise their head just kidding to make a
case
for which rook so i'm going to try
to gauge the crowd here some of you
think f
most of you think a let's play the um
you know what i'm going to play here
beautiful time for this
this this
i'll give you guys another 15 seconds
all right this is very fitting music
all right so the answer is rook a takes
d1
and i want to make it clear that the
difference here is marginal
but not everybody has detected the
reason properly the queens are off the
board
so there's no reason to there's no
reason to like
think that black is going to ever attack
my king black is not going to attack my
king
uh most likely so it's not that i need
the rogue to defend
the king but i asked myself where can i
put this f rook and what i
suspected would happen is that he would
take the pawn on e5
and i would respond with bishop takes c5
but
forecasting this uh into the future
i recognize that the e file might get
opened and guess what
it would be perfect to put this f rook
on the e file if i had taken with the
f rook then the other rook would have to
choose between these closed files and i
never really anticipated any one of them
opening in the near future
so what happened i played knight d5 here
boom boom boom the file opens and
i didn't end up putting the rook on
anyone but that's that's completely
beside the point
the point is i had this idea in mind
and it it actually influenced his play
and i won the game in the end
okay not the ideal example but uh
hopefully it
it clarifies things for you guys a
little bit exactly thank you
i can't wait for him to get older so he
slows down a little
well you know i'm trying to keep things
swift so it's entertaining but
as i always say if there's something
that you don't understand specifically
i always encourage questions if you'd
like me to repeat something that doesn't
mean you're dumb
it means you're invested in learning and
i will never take it that way
and nor should anyone else that's the
whole point of this in the first place
absolutely ryan so are you asking what
plan i'd have here or something specific
go ahead
i always um disagreed with people who
get annoyed when people repeat questions
as long as it's not in a trolley way
uh because it just means people want to
make sure they understand something
yeah ryan i'm i'm all ears so let me
well i can use the opening but i don't
know what to do after that oh so how do
you plan in general is your question
yeah so one of the biggest
misconceptions about planning
is that when like beginners think of
grand masters
they think of gm's having these 15 20
move plans these
long like major plans and that's
actually incredibly talk storm with five
gifted thank you
storm really appreciate that's a
misconception
mostly plans are two three four moves
maximum and that's why i define the
three move rule
to say that any idea that takes longer
three moves or longer is oftentimes
going to be unrealistic
uh because the position changes so fast
in most cases at a grand master level
that most plans consist of small
maneuvers i want to trade this one piece
i want to do this one small thing right
it's like running an
errand you're not planning for the rest
of your life there are exceptions to
that
sometimes the position can be completely
closed for example
and you can afford to make a 10-move
plan but those situations are definitely
the exception
rather than the role okay 43.75
i cannot believe it it's unbelievable
thank you
yeah thank you cezar
ah something like 50 14 1500
i don't play pull up like this how do
you determine whether it moves too
passive no formula but
you have to make a judgment call is it
more important to defend your king or
more important to
just start attacking
definitely ryan hundred percent they're
15 minute games 30 minute games
minimum uh
not that many i'll answer questions
since the server is resetting guys
now is your chance to ask some questions
i don't memorize entire games though
thank you phillipsburg well i've done
previous streams where i talk about
openings and i'll do that sort of
separately
why was playing king h8 a good preamp to
move
well because it got the king out of the
diagonal king h1
got the king out of the a7 g1 diagonal
so queen b6 wouldn't create discover
check ideas
so in the same ish um and this is the
reason the same ish um
it's 1am in california but it's 4am in
north carolina which is the important
part so
in the same ish you usually um
castle queenside which is what makes the
same-ish
quite unique among king's indian
openings usually in the king's indian
white castle's king side in the sameish
in most cases white actually does castle
queen said and go for checkmate so it's
a very dangerous line